Audubillahi mina Shaytan ar-rajim Bismillahir Rahman ar-rahim Allahumma saliya Allah Sayyidina Muhammadin mu 'ala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin kamas alayta wa salamta wa barakta wa rahimta wa tarahamta ala ibrahim wa ala ali ibrahim fil alamina inna kahamidun majid Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yasir li amri wa hlul qdatam millisani yaf qawli Salaam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu.
So in the previous session, we learned that Allah created us as nouns, right?
And just speaking in grammatical terms, we are all nouns in our essence, but then from the moment we wake up until the moment we go back to sleep, in fact, even while we're asleep, what we're constantly doing through our actions is
creating verbs so the power of Bismillah Rahman Raheem is that it provides a context for our verbs it provides a context for our actions by turning them into these reminders right by turning our actions into these heavenly lofty signs these Isim of Allah
reminding us of His intense and consistent love, care, kindness, concern and mercy which is His Rahmaniyya and His Rahimiyya.
And once we experience His Rubulbiyya, right, once we experience His Rubulbiyya through our interactions with this Alam that He created for us, because
All of our actions are only happening because His little boobia enables and empowers us to do that.
Right?
So, I'm able to drink water because He gave me this physical capacity to pour water into a glass.
And then He made water subservient through His laws of nature so that it obediently falls into the glass when I pour it.
It doesn't refuse.
It doesn't change its direction, right?
It doesn't just start rising upwards in mid-air.
It follows and obeys these laws of gravity that Allah created, allowing me, enabling me to drink it.
Now what is this if not a sign of the mercy and love of Allah?
where He enabled me and water to interact in this manner.
This is His action, His proof of Rububiya executed with intense and consistent love and mercy.
So now once I recognize and more importantly once I experience this love, what should be my natural response to that love?
It has to be Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen All praise and all gratitude belongs to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, the Rabb, the master of Alameen.
This is why the Basmallah directly connects with the Hamdullah.
Now in today's session, I want to do a linguistic study of this word Hamd
to demonstrate the perfection of the statement so that we can appreciate why Allah used this particular word and and why he used it in this particular fashion in this verse you know why didn't he choose a different style for saying the same thing so let's begin with the word Hamd itself
because this form of his diction it veils many many valuable lessons for us to learn from.
The word Hamd is actually a composite word that means two things.
It means praise and it means gratitude.
Right?
It's praise plus gratitude.
Now there are two other distinct words in the Arabic language for praise and gratitude.
The commonly used word for praise is madah and the word used for gratitude is shukr.
Now what's the difference?
Praise as we all know is a gesture of appreciation.
When you are moved by something that is beautiful or colorful or scenic
You know when something intrigues you in some way, when something impresses you, what do you do?
You praise it.
You verbalize your appreciation by praising it.
That's the very natural human response to something that our soul finds beautiful or impressive.
Now gratitude is something entirely different.
Gratitude is done in response to a beneficial act that was done for you.
Right?
If somebody lends you money or does something nice for you, you say shukran.
So gratitude is always done as a response to a beneficial act.
So you see the difference?
Praise is done when something impresses you.
or when you appreciate something about someone.
Whereas gratitude is done in response to a favor or a kindness that was done for you.
Now even though these two terms are used interchangeably in our lives, they're actually both mutually exclusive.
Someone you thank is not necessarily someone you praise.
Quran clearly distinguishes between these two concepts.
So for instance, in the story of Musa , we know that he was adopted and raised in the house of Firaun, right?
And then years later when Musa returns to deliver Allah's message to Firaun, he says to him, How dare you?
How dare you talk to me this way?
Did we not raise you as a newborn in this house?
Did you not spend many years of your life growing up here?
How dare you speak to me like that?
In other words, Firaun is saying, aren't you grateful?
I raised you for so many years and now you're going against everything that I taught you?
To that, Musa responds, Yes, you did in fact show me that favor, and for that I am grateful.
So even though Firaun is someone who will never be praised, especially not by a Prophet, but even when he does a favor, he will be thanked.
So gratitude can exist without praise.
You see?
In the case of parents, Allah says in Surah Al-Luqman, Wa wassainal insana bi walidaihi hamalat hu ummuh wahnan 'ala wahnin wa fisaluhu fi 'aamain anishkurli wali walidaih ilayal masir.
And we have made it compulsory, we have enjoined upon human beings the care for their parents.
His mother carried him
increasing in weakness upon weakness and then in his weaning which is in two years so be grateful to me and to your parents because to me is the final destination so be grateful to me and both of your parents but then he says
but if your parents are working against you in forcing you to disbelieve and commit shirk against me then do not obey them but you still have to be what you still have to be grateful to them in other words if your parents are forcing you to disbelieve in Allah you don't have to praise them but you still have to be grateful to them
Ibrahim is a good example of this, right?
He does not praise his father who according to the Quran was an idol worshipper, but he is still grateful to him.
So, Al-Madah and Al-Shukr, praise and gratitude, these are two completely separate things.
They are mutually exclusive.
You can praise without being grateful and then you can be grateful without praising someone or something.
But what's interesting about the word Hamd is that it necessarily means both things together.
It's mutually inclusive.
When Allah says Alhamdulillah He is saying praise is for Allah and gratitude is also for Allah both at the same time.
You understand the difference?
what the word hamd does is that it makes both these concepts of madah and shukr mutually inclusive one cannot exist without the other without within hamd it means praise and it means gratitude so now let's look at why Allah did not use the word madah and shukr and instead use the word hamd so let's start with madah why didn't Allah say
All praise is for Allah.
The problem with the word madah is that it is a praise that does not necessarily have to be genuine.
You see?
Because we all know that praise can be insincere.
Right?
A kid walks in the house with a really bad report card
And as soon as he enters the house, he goes, Mom, oh my God, your food, it smells so delicious.
And she hasn't even started cooking yet.
Right?
So he's praising her, but it's not a genuine praise.
You get it?
Because praise can be fake.
There is fake praise done for kings, for bosses, for people in all these high positions all the time.
Isn't it?
People falsely praise appearances all the time, right?
Wife asks the husband, you know, Does this dress make me look fat?
Oh no, you look beautiful.
That's madah.
This is why in classical Arabic when you praise someone's looks, you never say hamida.
Because everybody knows that the person that is being praised did not make their own face.
If they're pretty, if they're beautiful, if they're handsome, Allah made them that way.
So saying you're so beautiful would just naturally be considered madah.
Because it is understood in language itself that praising looks and all these external features, it is inherently a false praise.
Now Hamd on the other hand cannot be a false praise.
It cannot be insincere praise.
Why?
Because Hamd is generated in the heart by the awareness of the magnificence and the glory of the one that is being praised.
I'll say that again.
Hamd
The praise element of Hamd that occurs when the heart becomes aware of the magnificence and the glory of the one being praised.
The heart and the intellect together recognize that Allah truly deserves that praise.
So therefore Hamd can never be a false praise.
Because the Hamd of Allah is not dependent on a personal need.
It is never motivated by a personal agenda.
You see, it stems simply from being impressed by who He is, not based on what He does for us.
So I hope that makes it clear.
Now let's think about the word shukr.
What if Allah had said, All gratitude is for Allah.
What would be the problem with that?
Gratitude or thanks, it originates from the acknowledgement of a favor.
Someone does something for you that you appreciate, you thank that person for that favor.
You have a flat tire, someone comes along and helps you, you feel grateful.
And you express that gratitude by saying thank you.
So thanks can only happen when you have a reason to thank someone, right?
It is a reaction to a favor.
It's never something you start with, right?
You don't just walk onto a street, see a stranger passing by and go, Hey, you, thank you, right?
You never do that.
When Allah uses the word Hamd, which is a combination of both praise and gratitude,
There are certain rules that apply linguistically.
First rule is that the praise aspect of Hamd has to be genuine.
It can never be fake.
Second, the gratitude aspect of it is not reactionary.
You see?
So Hamd is sincere praise and it is not a gratitude that is in response to what he does for us.
Therefore, linguistically saying Alhamdulillah is far more powerful than saying Al-Madhulillah and it is far more powerful than saying Ash-Shukrulillah.
Because it is a lot more comprehensive than both of them.
Okay, so now what if Allah had said, Al-Madhu wa Shukrulillahi Rabbil Alameen Praise and gratitude belongs to Allah.
What would be the problem with that?
Even if we remove the shortcomings of both these words madah and shukr, the problem now is that when you put the word and in between the two things, which is the letter wow, right?
When you add that wow, that and in the middle, the problem is
that it separates both words even in meaning linguistically so when I say linguistically what I'm saying is that praise belongs to Allah for certain things and gratitude belongs to Allah for other things they're not always combined because the words aren't combined you see this is a very cool feature of Arabic language you never say what you don't mean
So if we use the two words gratitude and praise and join them with an and, in classical Arabic that means sometimes I'm in the mood to praise Him but not necessarily thank Him.
And then there are other times when I'm in the mood to thank Him but not necessarily praise Him.
But when Allah says Alhamdulillah, that means for every act that He does or doesn't do,
for every blessing he gives or holds back genuine praise and unconditional gratitude is due to him both at the same time we do not get to pick and choose which one so now if you own a nice car and you say Alhamdulillah what have you just done you've genuinely praised Allah for giving human beings
this knowledge and this ability to create cars to design and manufacture them and you thank Allah for letting him letting you own one so now you're praising and thanking Allah both at the same time and all of that is eloquently captured in the beautiful word hamd alhamdulillah this is why hamd
Is the attitude of a true believer, because it is optimistic by its.
nature you know sometimes you're going through a difficult time and somebody says how are you doing and you say oh you know life sucks but Alhamdulillah so you're not really praising Allah or thanking him when you say Alhamdulillah that way right Alhamdulillah is not a phrase that believers just throw around because it is the reminder of an attitude
Allah is never interested in what comes out of our tongues he's more interested in what's in our hearts that is connected with what comes out of our tongues so when a believer says Alhamdulillah regardless of the situation or circumstances the sentiment that resides in his heart
is that indeed without a doubt all praise and all gratitude belongs to Allah regardless of my situation if I'm going through a difficult time and I say alhamdulillah what I mean is indeed my praise and my gratitude is for Allah because no matter what I'm going through it could always be worse
someone right now in this world is going through a much harsher version of what I'm going through right now and he can then say the same for somebody else and that person can say the same for somebody else because no matter what problem we go through it could always be worse so I'm grateful to Allah that he is lenient with me I'm grateful to Allah that he has provided me with the resources to fix my situation
Because there might be someone who just doesn't have the same resources that I do.
And I praise him for his majesty.
And this acknowledgement of how the one who gives help can take it away.
And then restore it whenever he desires.
Because my pain is supposed to remind me of all the times Allah had me living in discomfort.
in which I forgot about him.
So Alhamdulillah, sincere praises and unconditional gratitude belongs to the one who reminded me of His grace and His blessings by temporarily or even permanently taking it away.
Alhamdulillah, sincere praises and unconditional gratitude belongs to the one who filled my life with undeserved blessings, even in my state of pain, even in my state of difficulty.
So an understanding of Alhamdulillah can really empower us and it can completely transform our attitudes towards life itself as believers.
Now let's look at this term from a grammatical perspective.
In language, we have nouns and we have verbs, right?
We all know the difference.
Verbs, they have tenses, whereas nouns, they don't.
There's no past tense nouns or present tense nouns or, you know, future tense noun.
So now when I say I praise Allah, I praise Allah,
Am I using a noun or a verb?
I'm using a verb.
It's a present tense verb.
But when Allah says praise belongs to Allah, is the word praise a noun or a verb?
Here it's a noun.
You see, Allah could have used a verb.
He could have said Ahmadullah, I praise Allah.
He could have said Nahmadullah, we praise Allah.
But Allah did not use a verb.
He used a noun.
Why?
Because when I use a verb, there's obviously going to be a tense associated with it.
So when I use a present tense to say I praise Allah, then I'm only talking about the present.
I'm not saying anything about the past or the future.
You see?
If I use the past tense, then I'm not guaranteeing anything about the future or the present.
Because the verb limits and confines the action within time.
It makes the action temporary.
But Allah used a noun, which by its nature is permanent.
Therefore, Allah's genuine praise and unconditional gratitude
It has been described with permanence.
And what that means is that I may be praising Allah right now, but the praise of Allah has always been there and will always be there.
I'm not going to be here in this world forever, but the praise and the gratitude of Allah is always going to be here forever.
His praise and His gratitude is not dependent on me.
It's not dependent on you.
It's not dependent on this world.
This is a huge reality encapsulated within Alhamdulillah, this concept of permanence in the praise and gratitude of Allah.
It is a recognition of the fact that Hamd is not dependent on my temporary existence.
Hamd is not because of me.
See, when you use a verb, somebody always needs to do the verb, right?
It's called the subject or the file in Arabic.
There has to be a doer for an action.
You can't just go into a conversation and say, fail the test.
Who failed the test?
Right?
You can't just say disappeared.
What disappeared?
Oh, your book disappeared.
You understand?
when you use a verb you always need someone to do that work but a noun doesn't need a doer a noun doesn't need a subject it is independent all by itself right an apple is an apple it can exist all by itself independent of any doer so when Allah used the word alhamd he made it a noun he made it independent
because he doesn't need anyone to actually do the praising and he doesn't need anyone to be grateful.
Had he used a verb instead that would have meant that he needed someone to praise him and he needed someone to be grateful to him.
So he removed the construction of time and space by using a noun.
Now what this means is that even if
there was not a single creation in the world, the hamd of Allah would still be there.
It would still exist.
Even after this world, this universe fades into non-existence, His praise and His gratitude will remain.
Because it does not require a doer or a subject.
Subhanallah.
All of this is captured by one single word.
used grammatically as a noun you know sometimes we have these questions kids sometimes ask this question like why does he need to be praised why does he need our gratitude so just the usage of this word the grammatical way in which the word Alhamd is used clearly answers that question that he does not need our praise and he does not need our gratitude okay now let's look at some other possible variations because I wanna I'm just going over this just to show you the perfection
that Allah has used in just one single verse imagine the entire Quran every single verse of the Quran is perfect in this manner and so just by appreciating one single verse we can really appreciate the entire Quran Hazrat Ali Sahib used to give this beautiful example that if you want to find out that you know if you're cooking rice and you want to know that the rice has been properly cooked you just check a couple of grains you don't check every single grain right
so I love that analogy because you know that's exactly what we're doing we just we're just looking at a couple of verses and and studying its perfection and that pretty much gives us an idea of the entire perfection of Quran so let's look at some other variations here what if Allah had said right what if he used a command praise Allah the master of Alameen now wouldn't that have been better
Because after all, he is a master.
So a command would just naturally make sense.
So why didn't he make it a command?
I'll give you an example to help you understand.
I tell my daughter to bring me a glass of water.
Right?
I say, Hey Adam, bring me a glass of water.
I give it a command.
Now once she hears me, she has only two possible choices.
She can either bring me the glass of water
or she can bring me the glass of water, right?
Those are the only two clear choices as far as I'm concerned.
So, now if Allah commanded us to praise Him, you know, as a command, what are the two things that could have happened?
Some would praise Him, some would obey His command, and then there would be others who would disobey Him.
Because when you tell someone to do something, the ball is now in their court.
Right?
It depends on them to comply with your wishes, with your command.
Maybe they'll choose to do it, maybe they won't.
Allah did not talk about His praise and His gratitude in a way that is dependent on us.
You see, He did not put the ball in our court.
He said,
whether you do it or not whether you are grateful to me or not whether you choose to praise me or not my praise and my gratitude my Hamd is always there it has always been there it will be there forever human beings will come and go nations will come and go generations after generations will come and go
this universe itself will come and go but the Hamd of Allah will always be there it is simply a matter of fact so now what if Allah had said certainly for sure absolutely no doubt about it Hamd is for Allah wouldn't that
sound a lot more powerful than just saying all praise and all gratitude belongs to Allah right it does sound more powerful doesn't so how come Allah didn't say so if you remember from our sessions on the miracles of Quran you know when we had that topic of conversation when I when we talked about conversation and communication itself
I told you there are two kinds of communications, right?
A communication can either be informative or it can be emotional, right?
It can be jumla insha'iya or it can be jumla khabriya.
Either you have speech that is expressing your feelings and emotions or you have speech that is communicating information.
Those are the two kinds of speech that human beings are capable of.
That's it.
Right?
So for example, right now, as I'm teaching you about Alhamd, am I delivering information or am I expressing my emotions?
I am delivering information.
This is informative speech.
But when I'm talking to my friend and I'm telling my friend how I feel about someone or something,
What kind of communication is that?
That is an emotional conversation.
So those are the only two types of speech that we as human beings are capable of.
The thing is that in Arabic linguistics, when you use inna, the statement can only be informative.
You see, it can only be factual.
It can never be emotional.
That's just a linguistic rule that if you use inna before a statement, it just becomes informative.
Indeed, we sent this Quran in the night of power.
It's information.
It's factual.
It's not an emotional conversation.
Because the word Inna removes the emotion out of the statement.
But if you don't use the word Inna, then that communication can be informative, but it can also be emotional.
You understand?
So by not using Inna, Allah made His Hamd an open statement.
We can now talk about Allah's praise and gratitude with other people in order to teach them about it, to give them information about it, but we can also make it a statement to express our own emotions.
SubhanAllah.
Can you appreciate the beauty of this?
So using this style right now by saying, Alhamdulillahi Abbil Alameen I am sharing with you, I am teaching you about Allah's Hamd.
A few hours later when I'm standing in Salat before Allah and I use the exact same phrase Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen I will be expressing my praise and my gratitude to my master.
The same statement will now become an emotional conversation for me.
Subhanallah.
So you can see how perfect the usage of this word is in the context of Al-Fateh.
So, I hope this really gives you a deeper appreciation of the perfection of this language and how one thing flows into another, how Alhamdulillah Rabbil Alameen connects with Bism Allah Rahman Rahim and how perfect the usage of this word Hamd is.
So, to summarize this entire concept of praise and gratitude in grammatical terms, we are nouns
and we create verbs through our actions.
Right?
We are nouns, Allah created us as nouns, as beings, as essence and we create verbs through our actions.
Now Allah is also a noun and He created verbs through His action.
This is Allah creating us in His own image.
Right?
Now on a daily basis we are interacting with Allah and He is interacting with us.
right, through his Rubbiya, over his Alam, He is interacting with us and we through our worship and obedience and praise, we are interacting with Him.
Now, in this interaction, listen to this carefully, in this interaction between us and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, for the recognition of the noun that Allah is, He is worthy of our Madaah.
He is worthy of our sincere and independent praise.
And for all His actions influencing our existence, He is worthy of our shukr, our ultimate and unconditional gratitude.
Alhamdulillah covers both aspects of our existence and His existence.
You see?
for the recognition of the noun that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is, for the marifah of His essence, which is impossible, but as much as we can learn about Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, our natural response to learning about understanding who Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is, He becomes worthy of our sincere praise.
And then for what He does for us,
how he influences our existence he becomes worthy of our unconditional gratitude both these concepts are beautifully perfectly eloquently encapsulated in this one single phrase all forms of sincere praise belongs to Allah for who he is
And all forms of unconditional gratitude, whether it's on a personal level or a universal level, it belongs to Allah for what He did, for what He does and for what He will do.
Because His actions are constantly manifesting on the stage that we call the Alam.
Therefore, Alhamdulillahi Rabbila Alameen.
Wa akhar dawan an alhamdulillahi rabbi alamin was salatu wassalamu ala rasuli he saydana muhammadin khatim aladiyin wasaidul mursaleen wa.
Ala aqihi wa wasiyyaalib nabi talib ashrafil wasiyin wa alal aimatimin zoriyati him ataibi natahirin wasalam alayhi majmain al-fatiha